several videos ago I very quickly went
through why side-side-angle
is not why it is not a valid postulate
and what I want to do in this video is
explore it a little bit more and it's
not called angle side side for obvious
reasons because then the acronym would
make would make people giggle in
geometry class and I guess we don't want
people giggling while they're doing
mathematics so let's just think about a
triangle here so let's say I have a
triangle let me draw it let me say let's
say have a triangle that looks something
like this if I have a triangle that
looks something trouble drawing straight
triangles so let's say the triangle
looks something like that it looks like
that and let's say that we've found
another triangle we've found another
triangle that has a congruent side a
side that is congruent to this side
right over here it has and then it that
is next to I guess any side on the
triangles next to the other two sides
next to that is a side that is congruent
to this side right over here and then
that side is one of the sides of an
angle so it forms one of the parts of an
angle right over here and that other
triangle has a congruent angle right
over here so this is the angle that that
first side is not a part of that first
side only that second side is part of
this angle so this is side side angle or
you could call it angle side side and
giggle a little bit about it now how do
we know that this doesn't by itself show
that this is congruent well we'd have to
show that this could actually imply two
different triangles and to think about
that let's say we know that the angle we
know that this other triangle has that
same yellow angle there which means that
the blue side the blue side is going to
have to look something like that it's
going to have to look something like
that
just the way we drew it over here this
side down here I'll make it a green side
this green side down here we know
nothing about we never said that that
this is congruent to anything if we knew
then we could use side side side we only
know that this side is congruent this
sides congruent and this angle is
congruent so this green side and I'll
draw it as a dotted line it could be of
any length we don't know we don't know
what the length is of that Green
now we have this magenta side and we
have another side that's congruent here
so this thing could pivot over here we
know nothing about this angle because it
could so it can form any angle but it
does have to get to this other side so
one possibility is that maybe the
triangles are congruent so maybe the
side does go down just like that in
which case we actually would have
congruent triangles but the kind of aha
moment - you're the reason why SSA isn't
possible is that this side could also
come down like this it could also come
down like this there's two ways to get
down to this base if you want to call it
that way you can come out that way or
you could kind of come in this way and
so that's why that's why SSA by itself
with no other information is ambiguous
it does not give you enough information
it does not give you enough information
to say that those triangles are
definitely the same now there are
special cases so in this situation right
over here our angle the angle in our SSA
our angle was acute this is an acute
angle right over here this is an acute
angle and when you have an acute angle
as one of the sides of your triangle the
other sides of the triangle you could
still have an obtuse angle remember
acute means less than 90 degrees obtuse
means greater than ninety degrees so you
could still have an obtuse angle and so
that's why this is an option so one
option is that you have two other acute
angles so this is also it could be acute
this is also acute also acute also acute
but then you had the option where this
is even more acute even narrower and
then this becomes an obtuse angle so
that is an obtuse angle and that's only
possible if you don't you can't have two
obtuse angles in the same triangle you
can't have two things that have larger
than 90 degree measure in the same
triangle and so that's why there is a
possibility where if you have another
triangle that looks like this if you
have another triangle it looks like this
and if I were to tell you and if I were
to tell you very clearly that this angle
right over here is obtuse if I were to
tell you this angle right over here is
obtuse and that is the a in the SSA so
you have the angle and I would say I
have another triangle where this angle
is congruent to that other triangle some
angle that other triangle
and then one of the sides adjacent to it
is congruent and then the next side over
is also congruent and the next side over
is also congruent and then it's not so
ambiguous because we could try to draw
that so let's draw that same congruent
obtuse angle let's draw we know nothing
about this side down here because we
haven't said that that's necessarily
congruent so that could be that could be
of any length we do know that this
triangle is going to have the same same
length for this side of the angle so it
looks like this it looks like this and
then we know that this side let me do
that in I'll do it in orange we know
that this side is also going to be the
same length and we haven't told you
anything about this angle right over
here so this side could pivot could
pivot over here we can kind of rotate it
over there but there's only one way now
that this orange side can reach this
green side now the only way is this way
over here and we were more constrained
or this case isn't ambiguous because we
used up our obtuse angle here the a here
is an obtuse one and so then it
constrains what the triangle can become
so I don't want to make you say oh maybe
SSA in general if SSA you do not you do
not want to use it as a postulate I just
wanted to make it clear that there is
the special case where if you know that
the a and the SSA is obtuse then it
becomes a little bit less ambiguous and
then finally there's a circumstance so
this is an acute angle where it would be
ambiguous
you have the obtuse angle and then you
have something in between which is the
right angle so where you have the a and
SSA is a right angle so if you had it
like this if you have a right angle and
you have some base of unknown length but
you fix you fix this length right over
here if you know if you know that this
is fixed because you're saying is
congruent to some other triangle and if
you know that the next length is fixed
and if you think about it this next side
is going to be the side opposite the
right angle it's going to have to be the
hypotenuse of the right angle then you
know that the only way you can construct
this and similar to the obtuse case is
if and if you know the length of this
the only way you could do it is to bring
it down over here so that actually does
lead to another postulate called the
right
right it's called the right angle side
hypotenuse postulate which is really
which is really just a special case of
SSA where the angle is where the angle
is is actually a right angle and here
they wrote the angle first you could
view this as angle side to side and they
were able to do it because now they can
write right angle and so it doesn't form
that embarrassing that embarrassing
acronym and this should also be a little
bit common sense because if you know two
sides of a right triangle and we haven't
gone into depth in this in the geometry
playlist but you might already be
familiar with it by Pythagorean theorem
you can always figure out the third side
so if you have this information about
any triangle you can always figure out
the third side and then you can use side
side side so I just want to show you
this little special case but in general
the important thing is that you can't
just use SSA unless you have more
information